hey what's up guys it's me Eric I'm
joined by Joey hello which can only mean
really one thing if we're streaming
together it means that we're streaming
over watch doom fist has been put into
PTR and the public tester has been
announced they've released the trailer
for it and he's playable all in like one
day yep but playable only on PC on the
PTR I'm gonna do this and then I guess
we'll move the PIP later because I don't
think top rights the best but you know
well we'll deal with it so there's doom
fist he's actually a offensive character
yes first no offense
sure I don't know for some reason in my
head before we started this stream today
I thought oh it's gonna be like a tank
like you know another tank yeah or maybe
like another kind of offensive tank
Allah like Roadhog erson yeah but yeah
guess not
anyways won't you yeah show some stuff
off work there's nothing in here oh
there's nothing all right that's fine
we're in the YouTube chat the twitch
chat glad you guys could tune in if you
guys aren't already subscribed to us hit
subscribes for more you know doofus
overwatch coverage as well as a bunch of
cool vods stuff that we do we live
stream every day at 11:00 and it hit
following on Twitch if you haven't also
we are on Facebook and GameSpot too so
thank you guys all for tuning in once
you get in the game or try to get into
it what what is it you showed me a seat
guys we do this elimination moonless at
least one at least Blizzard knew right
like they're like oh okay it's probably
gonna be everyone playing doom fist
let's just call it what it is and not
call it free mode or whatever yeah
arcade mode is all right let's take a
look at his abilities or once we get
into the game from what I know
Oh what's up Rohan samal when you go in
the game fast we are we don't know when
he's actually going live Charles bender
so who knows master story where's Terry
sad face I don't know where Terry is man
it's time right bad hop rates okay right
oh well that'll be okay I like this well
go
hopefully game work I'll kind of go
through his abilities so first one his
left shift or one of his abilities is an
uppercut which
knocks him into the air see if I can
find that last guy there he is
so he has an uppercut which has about
five second cooldown he has his uh I
think a rocket punch which looks like
you can charge it up mm-hmm I like that
that's his right click and then he has a
when you're in the air he has an ability
to kind of smash down to the ground you
can see that as II action we're just
charging up one punch oh I got okay
they're just just charging it around
here
let me fix this gaming hit so I guess
top left huh yeah top lips probably best
if I can find it chuckling says he looks
like a hobo I mean he does have a bunch
of ripped clothes hey man I just has a
big strong glove and on his left hand he
actually has a little hand cannon so he
can do some range damage like that
interesting his uh he has a 4 out of 4
for his ammo which I assume is like this
but it just recharges alright you not to
reload it yeah you can see it on the
blue the blue reticle or the blue of
icon like right in front
that should work yeah cool so fix the
pit we're back um I will try to field as
many questions as I can
yeah he's not a tank whoever said he's a
tank mr. Jenkins he looks weak AF he is
a dps character I would say though it's
like I was reading some stuff and people
brought up a good point that whenever
Blizzard releases a new character like
with an ax and Arisa they usually don't
they're like under tuned a little bit
yeah and then they kind of see what they
need to change to maybe potentially buff
them a little bit so we'll see I mean
it's really early people haven't figured
out how to play them yet just cool to
have them in here oh man he's got like
sure you can yeah the store you can oh
oh yes brain-dead blue where are you
were you yeah but there's a bunch of
trailers out as well if you guys haven't
seen it he doesn't have any intros or
anything right no nothing yet he has
nothing in there when we checked Qui Gon
Jinn CJ fan remember when everyone
thought ah no is bad like kappaface I
know oh you can this this update also
has the that new highlight intro for the
highlight system where you can save
highlights mmm like you see at the bomb
there was like press f9 to save okay
cool yeah so you know anybody could save
yeah so in addition to saving your own
highlights you can also save whatever
play the game was in your match it's
pretty cool hmm yeah that guy did work
right there we it is not Terry Crews
apparently according to most of the chat
I don't know I can't confirm or deny
that but seems like a lot of people are
saying it's not so
we can go with that I guess my my theory
was that he did the the character
modeling like a mocap yeah or maybe if
they didn't use mocap they use him as
like a model to to sketch out like his
body and his body shape because I'm
Terry Crews I got a look at doom fist
again let me take a look at doofus again
I feel like you know me look at that
look at how rip that is turqu ooze don't
have that like side six-pack whatever
that is are you sure does he I don't
know maybe can we flip like a picture
let me pull here we're ready this is
where we're going to already okay I got
a Wi-Fi device right there right there
on the top right top right small oh wait
he's pretty ripped that's pretty close
that's like a side head thing alright he
doesn't we'll do that after this let me
see if I can find another image of Terry
Crews but that one's pretty good he's
pretty he's flexing there he's flexing
yeah okay Oh Old Spice commercials
should we yeah shout out to okay yeah
maybe a little bit more of it from a man
to sized version of his body a little
bit alright alright won't do it in a
second we'll do it in a second oh I'm
going in merked
yeah oh one punch Satsuma said to mccune
to my own gun ooh that's good that's
good punch is pretty satisfying yeah see
that can you follow up with the uppercut
after that yeah so it's probably a combo
like charged up hit him once uppercut
and then slam down and then finish them
with the pistol they try to run or
something yes yes Leon he does have a
pretty good side pack going on I'll
compare it with the pictures you guys
can say oh oh that hit Oh get oh man
that's pretty that's pretty damaged like
anytime you're in you know you're lining
up oh you got nobody
mm oh you're so screwed here so it's
everyone I think what when he when he's
when he's cornered like that and you
have like no clothes you kind of it was
like kind of like when you're tracer and
you're out of like the kind of like the
warp ability yeah it's kind of stuck
you're like well I can't get out of here
thank his cooldowns or he has an
effective short okay I think the five
seconds okay is that the charged punch -
I'm guessing oh that's okay so how are
you getting stunned is that from the
charge plunger Oh
96 damage oh is it based off of range
like the hard or you can charge up okay
so it's oh I see I see the meter in the
middle okay my fault okay so so
basically like you like the four shots
your chart your punch also has the
different degrees yeah I guess damage or
like damage and also range
what is his ultimate says could ask for
pcs caffee's we haven't seen it yet
hopefully we get to it before the end of
the game we'll see what it is yeah
yeah I think I read it was a it's called
a meteor strike so he like jumps off any
comes back down okay
yagi guy says doofus is a combination of
Ryu Captain Falcon and Terry Crews I
like the I'm gonna go up oh you can't go
up that's good to know how does this
shield work Oh does he have a shield no
don't know what his golden weapon is
considering his punches already there is
a this is already gold shinier yes can
you do it got dunked on oh you're not
gonna get your super in time huh unless
I do really well at this round okay
punch he jumps up target area damage all
and range okay yeah so basically like a
Superman ground and pound or so yeah my
teammate oh I don't know everyone looks
the same look for red we're back oh I
bet Kelly to give him that Dikembe
Mutombo wag of the finger don't come
into this
oh he's charging Oh big so lying I don't
go man get him done though
can I shout out what's up Nolan offered
one punch in now in overwatch that's
correct
xxxx Spartan and he is now an overwatch
I guess the shield generated for every
attack yeah that was wondering like why
do I all the Sun have tons 75 HP okay
thank you so what was saying he could
get up to 400 yes video 50 right now
yeah I know he has
you ain't okay yeah okay that's pretty
cool looks like it deteriorates like
over time but oh so it doesn't stay like
to persist for damage oh it's just like
okay audio is busted uh hopefully not
you guys tell me but I think we should
be okay crazy cat
[Music]
Brent
7or Brett n7 sorry Brett n7 from what we
can tell he's gaining damage or sorry
he's gaining shield from his abilities
so he can get higher than 250 260 life
we can't show the golden fist because
we're nothing's available to show Oh
what I do need to pull up is I need to
add this Terry Crews when it appears as
golden this is golden because there's no
email show that going in again anything
except for this show the golden again
yeah so we wanted the Old Spice one
right okay there's the Old Spice one
this would probably be the last weapon I
get just because of how similar do you
think that looks like Terry Crews I put
the picture up those ABS look similar I
think so put him straight on where he
doesn't yeah oh whoops I guess I gotta
shrink this a little bit you should put
it over him it's like yeah there is that
why you guys want it take crews pretty
close it's yeah it's pretty close all
right let's go back in I'm gonna get rid
of this image or I'll save it maybe um
thank you daddy sauce I did see it and
he says he or she says audio is fine
thank you appreciate it
cool for the confirmation so yeah we're
pointing on PTR which is only PC so
unfortunately a console overwatch
players won't be able to see it
unfortunately but um you know hopefully
he gets released in a week or two but
who knows how long was it roughly after
erisa on PTR it was it was actually
fairly short I want to say about two
weeks okay so like hopefully in like one
to two weeks I remember correct will
maybe get Terry Crews so I'm like
reading chat I really chatted so what's
it take cruises turned them on and then
I want to say Terry Crews instead of
doing this but hopefully we got doom
fist and you know a week or two who
knows
oh man someone's actually playing real
characters well these are this is a
custom game so we have three 3v3 and the
rest are CPU oh all right
two of them are CPU I guess it helps
balance it a little bit because we have
healers here it's sure I think they give
the other team healers as well
Neville Ennis this should be 1080 60 you
should be able to see it in 1080 60 tell
me if you're not but it should be let's
let's do this is there any other funny
images I could put on on to pretend it's
like should put the muscle muscle and
fitness magazine cover you just put do
this on there crap we got hi seekies the
muscle fitness a little bit further up
or maybe further down where is it right
there
just need a cut of the mountain I can't
cut him out with this tool I can try
while we're doing this but I should
really be reading chat instead of I'm
gonna I'm just gonna read catch it's too
much work
YouTube Diamond sheep's as a hero that
looks like is Leeson kind of buddies his
kicks right we tie
we want more Terry's Hicks Oh God
oh no oh you got one oh I was like man
you crazy there's like uppercut though
that's like that how long will this
event last as step in three two one
I'm not sure but if you have a PC
overwatch you should be able to just
download the PTR patch and play sorry
we're gonna say did you have all know
ooh did that knock them up yeah oh you
have 300 really good oh the outplay oh
yeah oh yeah hmm
you don't know how to shoot it's a
Korean he was waiting as I think he's
gonna go after oh you almost rounded the
corner zoom I guess that's when you do a
random uppercut yeah because he said it
doesn't go up right which one it doesn't
go it doesn't not go up right the charge
punch no yeah like you can't you can't
go like angle oh that's actually pretty
good
Simon Eklund and zappy bring out kaboom
it's kind of like a vibe from legal
legends because she does have that one
move where I think it's maybe even her
alt or maybe one of her just her skills
this move it's pretty much like him like
by oh okay so we can see the alt now
neon void kind of speculating saying
based on how their old releases of
characters were hopefully by end of July
but that's like three weeks from now a
lot of us thought he was gonna be
defense but he is definitely an
offensive character and as mentioned by
God dig dig Z YouTube or Dixie ey key
days and
oh come on stupid on the CPU good thing
she didn't sleep you though so here's a
question so you know you have the circle
do you think the enemy has the circle at
all oh no they don't you're going out of
view of everyone you like kind of
disappear in the air you got to be able
to counter it though right yeah I'm sure
oh it's like damage and knock-back I
think yeah but I'm just saying like if
you're in the air based on how overwatch
is I would assume if Anakin's like you
cannot be seen yeah I don't know Ana
would be able to sleep you or on uh
sorry oh no you are like in the you know
I think the note2 said it said out of
view so I'm not sure if that means just
like really high in the air or if you're
literally like you cannot be seen
uppercut you have a little reticle too
when you're in the air you can see a
little that cone Parker not true
Parker Hawkins he he's saying that he
barely does any damage we just saw him
charged punch one guy and do ninety-six
damage to another dude that might be I'm
not sure if that's even fully charged
yeah but that's what I'm saying like
like you can do you can do some damage
this thing may not be able to do that
much it's like the finisher right oh you
got alt again I'll finish him where are
you oh oh
oh yeah oh yeah mmm what is that that
did not look like it did that much
damage you're so crazy
I like how we don't have to reload Oh
syrtis Oh Curtis Wang asking can you
charge financially pin the air with L
ship and then release the charge in the
air to take out a the idea of being to
take out afar let's test it
all right well test it out for you we
can't show off skins Poindexter because
there aren't any in the game the only
thing that's you cannot be or tune okay
the only thing that we saw was the
golden fist that's it
his primary fire sucks well I mean I
think that the the little hand kind of
thing is just to finish off the
stragglers as there yeah like damaged
and low like when you slam down and like
knock it into the air a little bit you
can like - go around him shoot the hand
cannon again he can't get up to what
Chad is telling me up to 400 health
potentially actually I had 350 at one
point see it this guy alright let's see
okay 25 like every every kill or knows
every hit oh dang he wrecked you guys
the Korean power Omar
Omer gyt he is current dude this is
available on the PTR on PC so that is
how you can play him right now he is DPS
mad gamer so can you explain again what
his alt does it's called meteor strike
and way does he just goes straight up
into the air and it's still to be seen
whether or not you can you're visible at
all but you have this huge target
reticle that's like a big circle on the
ground and you can choose one to land
and like deal damage to everyone there
okay does it and it pops them up right
is that what it was I think so I think
it does like a small knock back
we tried uh what is that the jeez the
only one gamer I think there was a lot
of numbers in there we tried the
shoryuken into the charged fist it
doesn't work either right oh you tried
to go up in here and then he asked to
like charge up and then jump like once
you're charged you can't do anything
else yeah I know but like you tried the
shore you can move and I didn't do it
that way
oh you charged all right let's try that
though we'll try that we'll try sure you
can into a charged punch sorry I thought
he tried that already
uh we'll show you the golden doofus
later well we don't know who he's voiced
by Anna goal 92 we're not 100% positive
in terms of if well Joey says that they
don't see where you land or like where
you are in the air like when you're
waiting up oh really
yeah sure okay what about the landing
though you don't think that they see the
reticle right no there's no way that
they can see that I uh
Momo's illusion will he be on ps4 at all
probably when he gets released probably
he will be when he's released - sorry
but he won't be on console for you if
you took like playable today unless you
have PC and complete PC know what is
this guy doing here he is pretty much
melee me Anora the only thing he has is
kind of like a pecking like a little
like that guys only range weapons are
you asking or no because they're saying
like how is he only like a melee
character because he's mainly melee
right yeah except for the little little
pistol gun thing yeah
the Joker there are no emotes voice
lines or highlight intros yet we don't
know if Terry Crews didn't voice doom
fist does not sound like him
it doesn't yeah I guess it's true but we
do have oh wait I can't even do it
because that's not gonna work I was
gonna fight Terry Crews picture up but
then I was like wait we don't have him
to show so it doesn't matter okay this
game
okay mode limits that way we can look at
doofus here and do this oh yeah that too
so here's his regular weapon and then
his gold weapon it's kind of polished
version of that real shiny well there we
go I can see it maybe did you guys see
it we're trying to get into a game Mason
trap we're trying we don't know who do
mrs. voice actor is Luke Gibson
unfortunately uh chuckling McGregor asks
do you think he's balanced for current
play it's hard to say like you don't
really get a good indicator doing what
we're doing because basically everyone's
trying to try out doom fist and you
don't know what that plays like in a
real life's like a real game setting
with like proper like one hero like
specific teams and whatnot I will say
though like as far as his abilities go I
think he's he's fairly balanced like as
far as the cooldowns are um you know you
never feel like you I can never seems
like I'm I always have something up like
whenever I won like I feel like I need
to kind of play safe like if I don't
have like my my charge punch or my
uppercut or something like that so I was
saying that they already confirmed that
it wasn't Terry Crews but I don't know
it's chat I can't so okay so Jael
confuse saying not voicing the character
there he is on the menu right there
number one oh can you pick them they
didn't choose takers but we don't know
if he didn't choose choose him for the
mocap or modeling of his body which you
know who knows he is DPS Fido 360
Alex hello we're trying to get into as
many games as we can to show up show off
do fist little Rick this kitchen ooh
you're a savage a lot of people making a
lot of lead to League of Legends
comparisons yeah some people saying he's
also like Gallio all right now here here
is attacks hand cannon short-range
weapon reloads automatically you only
have four shots which are seen like
right in the middle of the screen as a
meteor strike press Q to leap up into
the air move the targeting circle and
then press left-click to strike the
targeted area apparently I think as
poultrygeist was saying that the guy
that did the voice acting for the
witchdoctor in d3 is actually to do this
yeah yeah nice oh well I'm out I'm out
oh [ __ ] are you though she did just went
back in or Doomhammer says the dimitri
rising up print knocking a meteor
seismic slam leaps forward and smash the
ground mad gamer asking does doom fists
alt do any damage or is it a stun type
attack I think it's I want to say its
damage and maybe knock up but I'm not
positive from the one time we did it or
twice we did it twice like yeah I didn't
really know sure
hopefully someone in oh that's trade you
killed someone though right yeah you go
oh I guess well member area one if you
get hit we'll charge so that's full
charge right yeah you did 91 damage to
you but that's not even anyone damage
that sounds like 91 percent or like are
there new crosshairs
yeah you can customize a match okay so
someone wanted you to check oh I'm out
I'm out so you can't see him right now
we cannot see him
or can the already land no idea up no
but he just landed oh that was like a 90
something damage to probably huh
Oh too soon let's see flowcharts oh yeah
hundred damage at so that takes so full
charge punch one punch man that's one
punch man yeah go he literally got one
punched a eggs ends just don't forget
that even though he is a 250 health care
melee character hmm he can gain shield
with every hit he does so like you can
see Joey had 270 his shield there but
it's progressively dropping so every
time he hit someone he's gaining shield
so it's not really just um
250 just keep that in mind oh the car
gotcha
ragdoll side to my sensei that's right
it's like alright you got a little jenos
in you but a little bit of a mostly
Saitama if you hit a hero against the
wall and stun them with the punch it
does more damage according to New
Castle's oh yeah yeah look at these
uh-oh dude that's cool I like her oh my
group is basic melee does more damage
deaf man 1 4 5 asking do you think
somewhere could be a possible counter
since he's gains armor with his ability
so hacking keeps him at 250 and easier
to hit he would be pretty [ __ ] without
his abilities yeah actually because he
would only be able to do that a little
for shooter this thing it's pretty weak
yeah and he would never be able to get
away so yeah it's pretty good thought
okay I have my old doofus is offensive
Russian crazy name that I cannot
[Music]
land please ah so you can okay so I mean
it was a very it's hard to say because
we didn't actually see him right so like
yeah actually that's a good point
someone saying hacking would be what
might not stop him from gaining shields
it's the EMP that would get rid of the
shields but after him would at least
make him pretty useless but I guess
hacking makes a lot of people useless
right so yeah but I mean even more so
since his primary fire is pretty bad
arming is pretty weak compared to like
the abilities they have you tried the
uppercut into the charge fist oh I
should do that now so it works yeah okay
so for whoever asked earlier you can do
sure you can into charge bucks that's
kind of cool cuz I get it that per
Farrah's right yeah his um his sure you
can heat after you do it he has a little
bit of a float to it like afterwards
miss well I'm out so your gun doesn't
give you shield though it's all it's all
your Oh glass died though right no he
felt he done oh no I'm not sure they all
the same
that was weird because you didn't get
the elimination I thought he fell into
the hole nothing here he doesn't have
any emotes outside of like base right
yeah he just sounds like the heroic one
which is him standing there like a mouse
I think you got to aim that thing more
that was hold of that organ ship oh yeah
get that help oh oh oh you guys some
heels though okay we're good so far
after two oh no oh you came down yeah
damage oh I think so it yeah yes it's
older man oh no oh oh you can't oh you
see the circle at the very last video
okay ooh here see you later
oh wait he could sure you can battle up
though yeah I don't think he got though
yeah yeah feels bad he feels bad he's
right charging to you one point maybe
about oh dude he goes hella far I went I
really like almost like a Winston it's
like a Winston jump almost it's like
slam dunk did you go pretty far with
that yeah like you kind of have to be a
little problem oh yeah cuz like when you
knock someone in the air your your first
instinct is like okay I want to hit him
again and like slam like a forward cone
right yeah I've damaged okay well you
you kind of have to anticipate where
they're gonna land and then like target
up for there is he in vulnerable when he
alt it kind of seems that way because it
doesn't like we haven't been able to see
a doom piss in the air like you're
completely go oh hello oh that's prob
about a Miss that's why not a pit right
it's like a downstairs I don't know what
he's looking at
okay who's a voice of doom fists ass Bob
Jones 1980 from what we were told in
chat earlier they were saying it's the
guy that did the witch doctor in d3 and
I kind of make sense to me kind of makes
sense I'm not 100% sure on that I'm just
trusting Chad so Chad please don't fail
me
the fights out oh oh meteor strike just
killed someone oh here they come
oh you're so dead oh oh you never die Oh
someone's meteor
oh yeah fault come on oh oh no someone
do it after you and you didn't take
damage oh yeah where's that far up okay
we're gonna team kill oh that was good
I'm having this is pretty great actually
it's a nice change of pace cuz I don't
feel like he's pretty different you know
he's someone saying if you Alt into the
pit there's no way back out that's not
true because I saw someone sure you can
up through it foxy we don't know the
release date this is currently only on
PTR the public test realm on PC again
we're streaming to YouTube twitch
Facebook Twitter even thank you guys all
for tuning in we really appreciate it
I'm Eric that's Joey Joey's are
currently playing a doom fist we
appreciate you guys hanging out with us
chatting with us asking us questions if
you haven't already followed us on
Twitch that helped us a lot
same with subscribing on YouTube so you
guys know when we go live with cool
content like this or other cool features
and whatnot that we make so please
please help us out and again appreciate
you guys tuning in watches
I miss them whenever I'm on the point of
my watching okay so there pushes them
back yeah pushes them oh my god that the
height and you know we gotta do try to
get on the far I know I bet you
everyone's trying to get her oh you
missed it's like rock paper scissors oh
I like that I like the attempt oh good
night oh good night oh yeah okay any
Michael down you didn't charge it long
enough I don't think but the fact that
you landed an article like just punch
her out of the air we're trying to do
this Shore you can mediate what we're
trying to be sure you can one punch man
on the can't you punch far in there and
he just did it more or less he got her
as she was coming down but he was
targeting her for like the the peak of
her job she was also I was not charging
that oh that does pop them up the ground
pound yeah hashtag one punch man that's
right can't wait for season 2 where the
Buffalo grazes he is an offensive
character trying to see if I can direct
the rocket punch you can a little bit I
saw so well I saw like I'm guessing it's
where your reticle is right for it where
it lands he's just slide sideways it
looks like you can along go wandering oh
so if you see him
okay so you can't stop it really then oh
I just heard another meter straight cars
oh here are never dimes oh you got it
too
on the mercy oh good night Oh double Oh
Oh Farah you press f1 for them real
quick so those are his moves
if you're curious there's the passive
the best defense was a good offer damage
increases if the enemy hits a wall
I like that mm-hmm just like that second
stuff man
that's a second stuff he is not a tank
Jedi logic says I just subscribed thank
you for subscribing we really appreciate
it our unit volume Bowl when you rock a
punch no you're not oh oh yeah yeah yeah
right to the mercy oh god oh three sick
or 180 to you at least duty yeah watch
because you go right by him right oh you
miss him he's charging around he's like
falcon punch falcon punch can you block
the fist
I don't know nobody's playing Ryan hardy
no oh it says it can go through shields
yeah Geoff Kaplan actually just mention
like oh if you do it on a rhino you're
gonna go right through okay so that's
why people were saying like rip
Reinhardt here Jeff where is everyone
Jonathan to saying he thinks doofus
still needs work it's hard to say it's
it's day one man real hard to say oh
come on you know what I want oh I want
that but you know what I want yeah
merci first
oh did we have a point yeah Farah I know
you're there why would you raise them
there oh my god
spec 8 beckon spec another girl 1983
doom Fitz is only on the PTR PC so you
need to have PC overwatch to be oh he'll
be playing this meet your stank oh oh
can you get hurt and stuck oh good night
thank you for the f1 says avocado
atrocity yep no problem
don't know when he's gonna get released
this is amazing someone just done sup
that's ok sub for f1 that's cool so we
got it back I saw Bruce as Paul plays
whitey thank you you seem so hard to
control I think it's one of those things
just got used to it yeah oh dear God ps4
Afghan jihad one punch man Ken Kenji
deflect it no we don't know when it
comes out on console it's just whenever
he gets released proper I hope they make
a captain falcon's get this bus blaster
oh five oh yeah also if you guys haven't
seen the the animated short check it out
right now while we're in between matches
yeah
downloading PT RSS feathers of Eagle HD
cool man awesome Farah the ultimate
counter I don't know man you can sure
you can falcon punch art it's really
hard to lay out the right height because
oh yeah because once you wherever you
get is the highest you're gonna get
right and it doesn't punch up so yeah
true so what do you think bard you like
him yeah he's probably I feel like out
of like besides McCree he'll probably be
my like attack mean dang yeah he's like
I've always liked melee characters like
Ryan Hart school but he's a little bit
tough to actually go in and start doing
your hammer wears what doofus is just
you're you're once you're in you're like
this is wrecking stuff I hope they make
a robot use fish skin says Cody 100
that'd be cool I mean like he's already
halfway there right you could kind of
reminds me of Jax
oh yeah okay except it's a one arm
instead of two arms uh pixels saying
ERISA is doofus counter don't know maybe
see I have no IDE through that shield
though Luke Callaghan asking Callahan
sorry Callahan asking how long do you
stay in the air with meteor shower or
meteor strike meteor strike you stayed
in the air for a while
that's a while like I feel like even
after you click he doesn't come down
right away there's like a second delay
mm-hmm
scrolling 19 saying Farrah is a hard
counter to do fist I could see that but
still we're gonna get oh do what they
had a sight to my skin who's that that's
one punch man dude keep blowing it was
it would be hilarious
I don't think they would they could do
it but I mean look at ginji's though I
need oh that's him I had no idea oh damn
it there isn't like a good give me a
good picture that for the second one
right there yeah I guess I guess I mean
just give him the tape and the the
orange suit and he is bald ready yeah so
I mean I could see it
see someone's asking about the
difficulty level apparently he's three
stars which supposedly the most
difficult I don't see it really you
don't think he's three stars I would say
to really like it might be okay go ahead
I was just gonna say it is probably just
because he has like a good number of
abilities here don't have to like Ord
yeah I guess those to me a lot of those
feel like skillshots
kind of stuff right like rocket punch it
looks like you can easily miss it
right rising uppercut in to seismic slam
like you're not that easy you have to
like you have to time it you have to
like aim where it is you know what I
mean where's like I don't know just
having a gun is like generally easier
right I don't know that's how I feel so
like I could see why it's a three star
compared to someone like who else's 3
star I think like this is Aria 3 stars
or as far as attack I think Ginji is
yeah he's 3 okay can you see the doofus
golden weapon show a shine that's uh by
the way that's one punch man if anyone
didn't know but I feel like most of the
people in chat know who one punch man is
if you haven't watched one punch man
I implore you to watch it it is a great
funny action-packed anime only either 12
episodes of 13 episodes really short and
season 2 is almost coming out so now is
the perfect time
plugging anime cuz you know that's what
we do that's what I do
where are we in I think pro Ganges tune
fist is one punch man that's right
there's the golden fist as it were big
and shiny what is PTR asked mr.
Nickerson that's the public test realm
if you launch your Blizzard app on PC
assuming you have PC when you pick
region you can pick the PTR public test
realm in which case you'll be able to
download it and then play Doom fist for
free assuming you're on PC not on
console unfortunately the game found but
there's an error starting them l Matt
we're trying to find a game trust me
we're not just here to talk I know I
know the feeling
we got Terry bears mm-hmm
we can't show skins he doesn't have any
thank you racer Lambo for also putting
that into the chat what is this all to
zalta isn't meteor strike yeah we want
you explain so basically he just jumps
up straight into the air and you have a
huge target reticle on the ground which
you can move I'm not sure how long you
can stay up in the air I want to say
maybe like five seconds at most like a
decent amount of time though yeah and
then you like slam down we're trying to
still figure out if how much if any it
does damage for sure cuz you killed one
guy with okay I saw it and it did 60 but
I don't know if that was 60 just from
the alt or you hitting him before yeah
DJ nicodemus asking can you control the
rocket punch wall in the air after you
do the the shift or the the risings
before you can you can technically do
the charge punch and you can aim that
right yeah yeah but as far as like
controlling like if you were to go like
this like you can't direct it you can
only go straight iron diamond what's up
there's your shoutout glad you're here
in the YouTube chat defense class is the
Forgotten class in over a wide range of
is there like the only class that's not
really in the meta
the metas right now Arthur can it that's
a assuming I said your last name right
sorry if I didn't
William Homer we don't have they no he
doesn't have a play of the game yet and
his email is just a normal heroic emote
no yes shall I say no typed explosion
pocket Mon
shoutouts to you best counter potentials
uh we're pretty sure far as one someone
said Arisa I don't know though if that's
true or not Farah I could totally see
though because it's pretty hard for him
to get up in the air and deal with the
her in there but she does have the
ability - nice nice Oh
Haman chop them thank you what's up Bob
Gojira sorry if I said your name wrong
z400 was shield as shifty I think no
shift est switch that's correct so his
passive gives him the ability to gain
shield from his of dad by doing them
damage with disabilities
sorry I'm just fumbling on my words a
little bit PTR does not cost any money
trend oh so as long as you have PC
overwatch you should be able to switch
to PC are in the region section of your
Blizzard app for overwatch and download
it for freedom and test out do this what
punch and in a couple and jenos finish
them off
oh not today sir oh sure you can already
go oh he did the he did it back to you
oh maybe that's the same timing but you
won't punch that guy though oh you did
stun him and then when he's done you
back yeah I mean for anyone that's
curious about balance or anything really
hard to say I mean this is not a good
way to show like what he's capable of
doing
you killed nobody
so now you see he's got 325 whoa
you can't go up can you charge no it's
always straight oh think you're doing
here
nice someone's chasing you though I got
a creep Macrina Bastion here too Oh his
melee punches into his actual doofus oh
it's a little baby him Duke this right
here is how I'm gonna get them okay you
should do one punch into the small punch
look it look at the Ginji - yeah yeah
and then if they run away then you shoot
him right yeah as Alex mentioned in
YouTube chat you can get a lot of
information about doom fist out on play
over watching YouTube they have the like
little animated short which is like
pretty awesome developer update with
Jeff Kaplan so if you need more detailed
information you can do that for sure
Oh get out of there you got three help
Oh does he say rising uppercut yeah
that's awesome oh oh - down so you just
so you guys know - um you do see where
he's gonna land like at least a second
yeah but you'll see at least where he's
a man that guy was in here
Mima supreme cool name do you think
Zarya alt + meteor strike would work I
think it would work but he you would
almost have to queue up the meteor
strike right yeah before or do a long
have to do it pretty quick Oh Oh God you
got no hops that time it wouldn't kill
them though I don't think just because
uh I don't think his leadership does a
ton of damage mmm it's definitely not as
good as like a tracer bomb or like a
Genji alt yeah wombo oh no nice
slamma-jamma there's health so no right
saying I mean Sombra I'm gonna be kickin
doom fist aces maybe my tiara asking are
the no duplicate crates in the same
patch as do fist I think so it was in
the last PTR um so I assume that the
same build
rising up out of cut oh he had one
health why don't you shoot him you're
fighting so much like a man try and do
the the slam what category I'm guessing
is what you think he's an offensive hero
yeah class Oh mistake Kimbo Slice 2.0 is
this a pre like post drug Kimbo Slice or
when he was doing hobo fight cuz you as
a beast when he used it in hobo fights
but I'm pretty sure cuz he was on drugs
I don't know if you ever seen Kimbo
Slice hobo fights you can check that out
I guess but that's kind of I wouldn't
tell the kids to watch that does he have
alternate fire modes no right no no not
that can think Oh unless you call his
left hand as the alternate fire I mean I
guess right I guess you could say that's
his alternate fire yeah you would McCree
yes thing he has nothing to protect
himself he's like he can only like
charge out of the way maybe someone
darnit
chess going so fast uh door door jamb
door John Luke asking what do you think
of a story I'll let you go for that one
I need to rewatch the intro again or the
I need to actually listen to it because
I just wore a Russian Earl I get in to
play shout me out please says where did
it go SIMEX music Pro shoutouts to you
okay spot says fab rows 56 so what
happens if he punch right into
reinhardt's charge it'll kill him it's
like on him right yeah just like any
other melee attack against Reinhardt you
can go right through the shield
oh no he's saying what if Reinhardt
charges Oh like dude uh it's Bailey stop
you right yeah they like knock each
other down with a second but the thing
that's interesting though is doom fists
would do damage though right because
I think I'm pretty sure you take damage
as well if you are another Reinhardt
charges in culture I think okay there
are no skins Reeboks Sasuke
unfortunately no skins no highlight
intros no emotes Stefan Vale Beale
Stefan Beale shoutouts to you know in
the YouTube chat thanks everyone again
for tuning in and YouTube twitch
Facebook all that fun stuff Twitter me
and Joey here if you haven't followed us
on Twitch give us follow that it's
always cool we stream every day at 11
a.m. we started a little bit early today
because of doom fist coming out early
obviously but yeah also helped us up on
YouTube if you haven't already
cuz you know then you can check out cool
live content every day at 11 a.m. or
cool amazing awesome features that we do
from time to time like reboots history
us by John Luke and different cool
features by Joey - I'm sure he'll do a
hero guide for doom fist once we get
proper version Slayer gaming what's up
man shoutouts to you in the YouTube chat
don't rod over someone saying he seems a
little Opie it's hard to say I don't
think you can say Opie or weak until you
actually see him in a proper game of
like just one doofus and how he can how
he fares against everyone else oh I saw
someone asking about a weakness
I think his weakness would probably be
like airborne people so Farah yeah so
because his his his main fire is his
little Hank in and that does not reach
far at all yeah it's kind of like um
Sombra like kind of close up kind of
stuff right like even worse and that's
powerful than sometimes you can only do
for two time they um recharge it's like
a big slate doesn't a spread right yeah
okay ah there was a good question dark
flame were shout out to you those are
the Divas attack I think yeah can you
cancel your rocket punch let's find out
no okay joke van roy you can do the
shift and then the rocket punch in the
air you can do that however your rocket
punch doesn't go up so you kind of have
to like either weight on your reticle to
like punch whatever's in your target or
kind of like aim it for like a straight
kind of attack yes ooh fist is not on
xbox so you can go do something like
this where no idea when he hits console
Curtis Maura and I'm Erin do you know
how far has alt goes I think it's just
as far as you can get in like five
seconds like it I I guess the next time
I'll do it I'll just keep going until it
runs out and see how far I can go uh
have we heard any like interactions
voice interactions with him and any
other characters yet no yeah it's just
all to other doom fists maybe if someone
picks a Reaper we can we can see has
mole money at zero Ken Sombra dunno how
do we get stuck in Q in this middle of a
game yeah what the hell I can still hear
the music go I can't do what is this
Rihanna Dan the English shout out to you
are you know what we should do I'll tab
don't get out Q obviously cuz that's a
real bad mistake someone say you can
cancel it left click right that doesn't
we don't left-click just do the attack
no that'd be the hang em all in one okay
we can try it in a second
thanks for that tip that was left a
couple people saying left click to
cancel yeah
Alex Walker we couldn't see a dufus in
the air when people are all ting but
we've only tried to look like once or
twice so hard to say you would think
that he would be able to get countered
though so who knows I'm definitely not
playing Bob so even if I was doing so
good at kick me it didn't do it why
don't we play the trailer or the the
character video while we're waiting
because we clearly have a thousand in
front of us too
so you can alt-tab we're gonna play the
animated short for you guys for the time
being and we'll shut up while it goes on
so we're waiting in queue just for those
people who are curious
every battle makes us stronger
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
those who fall will be forgotten those
who rise up their names will be
remembered forever I would watch that if
they just made some animated yeah we've
all been clamoring about like over
watching TV show if it looked like that
oh dude I would watch that you want to
see if you made it in 400 players
because we're close yeah I know it's
weird
okay so I was watching that and just
thinking okay so tracers shooting him
right yeah and he's not even moving does
that mean like he's just dodging a hella
fast without even like so fast or it's
like he's just taking all of it and
going like ah it does your gun like
actually doesn't do it hit him yeah like
maybe he just got a bunch of shields
from hitting Ginji or something like
that but then like there wasn't like the
cool like little like it would really
cool to see like little like blue the
flash like flashes like coming up to be
like okay like her guns are doing
nothing because he has shield Luke Cage
enemy looks great and it's crazy too cuz
he punches through a wall of concrete
and his hand doesn't bleed ever but I
don't think you got ever show blood
because that becomes M rated which is
why Marvel never shows what pg-13 ah so
hopefully get back in 40 players sorry
guys that we got kicked dropped out
there oh no great what is this here I'll
go to camera a welcher I'll try putting
this one in we got a camera here real
Khloe we're not sure why that happened
to you because that seems kind of silly
but you might as well exit the desk
topping this is bad though because you
said it doesn't work it from the
authenticator a sheet feels bad
we waited in a fake queue to only have
to then have him try to log in so we're
gonna try to get back in here hopefully
apologies I know
back in queue sadness
oh let's see do you feel that carry
cruise on the desktop you feel like
anyone else is going through this right
now probably a couple people that's fine
4,000 at least I feel like that's a fake
arbitrary number that like yeah okay so
other people there's you know people are
in the same boat they are back in
they're like stuck in queue he'll so
we'll see if we can get in this time
[Music]
after this this time if it doesn't work
then you know we got a good hour worth
in so you want to show like the
developer update or something that is
owning diamond 17 shoutouts to you in
the YouTube chat thanks for tuning in
thanks everyone for tuning in and sorry
for the current thing once you pop that
yeah oh here we go
gonna watch the dev update for the time
being as we're stuck in cube I think
this is the one that you guys have been
waiting for
we're here to finally talk about doom
fist so I'm Jeff from the overwatch team
as you guys know doom fist is one of the
most anticipated heroes that I think
we've ever talked about he's our 25th
hero he hell's to us from Nigeria
so he's West African one thing you may
not have known is that doom fist is a
prominent member of the Talan leadership
so contrary to popular belief Reaper is
not the sole leader of Talon there's
actually a Council of leaders who
oversee Talon and sometimes they agree
with each other sometimes they disagree
with each other and doom this is a very
important member of that Talon Council
now doom ffice ideology is that he wants
to see humankind become more powerful
and he thinks the way for that to happen
is through conflict so it's kind of a
harsh world view but he really believes
that we as humans get stronger the more
conflict that we in
or obviously overwatch is a world group
that's very opposed to conflict and is
trying to create peace throughout the
world so therefore it leads to doom
fists and overwatch definitely being at
odds with each other you add to the fact
that it was Winston who put doom fist
behind bars for many many years and doom
faced hatred of overwatch is at an
all-time high
now that doom fist is free he plans to
use talent to implement his world view
on the rest of not only talent but
mankind altogether so the story is going
to get very interesting now that doofus
is in the mix I think it's going to be
awesome that we learned more about Talon
through doom fists and his interaction
with heroes like Widowmaker and Reaper
but let's talk about his abilities and
what type of hero he is so doom fist is
in the offensive category he's a very
tough offensive type of hero he has a
number of great abilities that he can do
so probably his most defining ability as
his rocket punch by default we've bound
rocket punch to an alternate fire it's a
wind-up attack so the longer you hold
the button down the more powerful and
the farther your you'll go with that
rocket punch he uses that huge gauntlet
that he has on his right fist to throw
the rocket punch now there's a couple
cool things about it one you'll go
through barriers if you do it so if
Reinhardt's holding his shield up it
doesn't matter you're gonna punch
Reinhardt directly through that shield
the other thing that's really cool about
rocket punch is it does more damage if
you knock a hero back into a wall so
you're really trying to line up those
exciting billiard shots with other
heroes and and inflict heavy heavy
damage with the rocket punch now he has
some other abilities he can do as well
he's got an ability called rising
uppercut which as you guessed it is a
giant uppercut that leaps him into the
air and will knock his enemy up into the
air along with him now to mix with this
ability or combo with it really well is
an ability called seismic slam the way
seismic slam works is
doofus gets a targeting reticle whenever
he's in the air or has any sort of
altitude and he does a giant attack with
the back hand of that gauntlet that
stuns the enemy very very briefly not so
much stuns them as brings them closer to
doom fist so it allows him to do a lot
more sort of combo abilities with that
seismic slam it's kind of a small cone
shape that you'll see you'll immediately
recognize it by the visual effect that
we put on the ground when you do the
ability doom Fisk also has a primary
attack that's a simple gun that he has
which is a shotgun that's loaded into
each knuckle of his left fist and you
can basically fire off four shots very
quickly one out of each of his front
knuckles on that left fist or you can
sort of save them up and do them in a
more rhythmic fashion will give you a
user interface element that lets you
know you know how many shots does he
have in each one of those knuckles
before he can unload with them we're not
intending for doom fists to primarily
use this attack as the main thing that
he's doing or where he's getting all of
his kills from it's sort of to fill in
the other space as he's using those
really fun dynamic punch mechanics now
the thing you're probably wondering and
carrying the most about is what is doom
fist ultimate ability he has one of the
funnest ones in the game it's called
meteor strike when doom fist uses meteor
strike
he shoots up into the air he gets an
amazing targeting reticle that he can
draw across the map and sort of gauge
where he wants to land and when he
commits to it
doom fist will come crashing out of the
sky stunning and knocking down everybody
who's in that in that radius as well as
doing some damage to them so not only
might you just kill them outright when
you meteor strike on top of them if not
they're immediately laying down and you
can use abilities like rocket punch
seismic landling etc to do additional
damage by flowing all over the place
doofus is going to do a lot of flanking
and do a lot of
diving into enemy teams so we needed to
give him a passive ability to encourage
and enable that type of behavior so he
has a passive ability called the best
hockey fan let's check it the game guys
holding out with us this gains a
temporary shield
we appreciate why over time the shield
will decay and go what to do this is not
permanently shielded by this but if
you're really getting in there there's
got a lot of great combo abilities
you'll notice that your survivability is
much higher so this lets doom fist get
in there and Rumble a bunch before he's
just taken out it's really hard you know
diving in on six enemy heroes you're not
always gonna live but if you dive in on
two and land some punches
you'll stand a chance at surviving
because of that passive ability called
the best defense
thanks more so we think dude this is
really gonna shake up the lineup even
more so we think doom fist brings
tremendous character to overwatch he's a
really important figure you've known
about him since the announced cinematic
where that battle happened over his
gauntlet you've escorted his gauntlet
new Bonnie it showed up stolen doom this
is very core to overwatch we think both
his gameplay and his story is going to
make the game really great we hope you
have a blast playing him and we look
forward to hearing all of your stories
about what you weigh to hopefully help
thank you thanks Jeff
it is kind of like waiting for
rise of iron I guess I except I got in
like right away so I wasn't stuck in ql
um yeah so we're stuck right now we were
able to get through this queue earlier
but then what happened is at least last
time was that once we got to the front
of the queue and made us log in again so
if that happens again obviously we're
gonna stop streaming if all of you guys
are actually like waiting and like to
watch doom fist gameplay you can
actually scrub back in the DVR of the
YouTube live player and watch it that
way so we apologize that were stuck in
queue hopefully we get in this time if
not then you know obviously be the end
of the stream but we really appreciate
you guys sticking with us the the people
that have and PTR is the public test
realm if you have PC
overwatch you can go to the regions tab
and then select PTR install it and then
update it then you'll be able to play
deepest but I guess I'll ask Joey so far
today cuz he's mostly been the one
playing you know your thoughts on doom
fist how he will work in kind of like
the overwatch meta and stuff like that
he's fun like I'll say that first and
foremost like it's just fun being able
to charge because it's not like
reinhardt's charge where you could just
kind of go and see maybe catch someone
like it's really fast and whoever you're
targeting most likely you'll hit it like
as far as his place in the meta like
it's like day 1 it's really hard to say
yeah he seems like good against tanks
because you know since he is melee like
the shields will do nothing for for
those like Reinhardt or IRISA or
something like that
so it's like good to get in like open up
abilities for the rest of your team that
way and as Jeff mentioned he they want
to they want to use him as kind of like
a want him to be used as like a flanking
type character which makes sense
yeah cuz people against walls and stuff
yeah or like he was saying like cool
shot like like yeah a couple pillows
like that made me wonder like if
someone's charging with a Reinhardt and
like he catches someone if you can
charge that guy caught in it
that would be like perfect timing though
you can't get PT on ps4 unfortunately
Leo Connelly it's only on PC
Josiah Shaw thank you for your patience
and thank you for the kind words let's
see
there is no skins yet yes as Evan
Lawrence has told panda bear 200 players
ahead of us do we know when it's gonna
be officially out asks Melissa Leo no we
do not unfortunately if you go off the
timing for like ERISA it was like I
don't know it was it 2 weeks or
something after like a week maybe so it
was faster than we thought though yeah
unfortunately again Alexander Winer Hall
or yeah why not all you can't play on
xbox pc only currently PTR at least he
just gave his thoughts on doom da new
fists he looks fun to me it's hard to
say it come on
we're searching yeah entering entering
actually oh wow we're back someone was
asking about if IRISA Keller is doing
this which it does which well we could
try countering yeah but that people are
gonna be mad at us because we're not
playing doofus so what do you guys want
you guys want us to try to counter to a
do fist or do you want us to play doom
fist I know the moment we should we
start playing the counters everyone's
gonna be like wait what is this called
doofus livestream and then there's no
doofus
well I was just mention that because in
the story like ERISA was made to counter
doom fist like yeah and the more I'm
thinking about the more it seems likely
that she's a good counter because
because she does have like her ability
to to like treat you like you treat gold
like stops all like knock down so you
can't get stunned
once you try it then let's just try it
real quick Arisa we're gonna try Arista
real quick for science England show
don't get mad halt
she can slow them down like that
[ __ ] like once once he slowy yeah you do
much suck him back down it is like up in
the air all right we're gonna try
countering doom fists really quit the
robot made to counter doom fists like
hopefully we'll see if it works out
we'll play doom fist right after though
cuz he can just go through that right oh
that didn't do that much damage though
oh come on oh yeah you could add to that
when they're all shooting at me though
uh pro-pro yo for shout out to you in
youtube chat so that seemed like decent
like if you didn't have to deal with
like five dude yeah we'll play doom fist
in a second we just wanted to see if
this works or not okay so for story
purposes for story purposes Aristo has
made the counter doofus so we need to
make sure it's canon oh god we don't go
back out to him okay you're good oh he
gained so much shield from yeah this one
I guess all the damage that it does okay
we switch back alright switch back
everyone's everyone's getting antsy
people are also asking about azaria use
that with meteor strike see how like how
much damage it would do
give them the baby here Oh giving him
the baby hand oh I didn't do as much
damage oh you didn't get against the
wall
hey finish him
hey Tychus relax I already know we're
already back on doofus everyone relax
Jesus we tried two rounds of erisa and
like everyone's freaking out I really
like how people in in like the in-game
chatter liking them as well yeah usually
you'll see you'll hear lots of cynicism
when you character comes out and be like
people are having a blast with only
thing rising up our cuts
whoa okay you took 200 damage from that
kill baby hand let's watch it watch it
right here with the assist from para
mighty Giro we've been playing that we
were playing that one mode that like
didn't have all DuPage but that's how it
goes every day one you know y'all are
good the rest are salty do science I'd
love to do science we're clearly like
everyone doesn't want the doesn't want
oh it felt like fgc right there because
uppercut it him cuz I saw him charge
also uh cancel the thing - yeah sorry
what are you saying I just waited you
can hold the rocket punch as long as you
want right oh but it does take up the
cooldown when you cancel it yeah but at
least you don't get stuck which is good
where the moose Rufus his shift-click is
a like kind of like an uppercut that
knocks opponents into the air that also
gives you the verticality and then his
Yi or the middle button it's kind of
like a like a slam almost like Winston's
slamming away you can combo that with
your shift and then your right click is
that rocket punch the one punch man Lou
and then his alternate fire which is
left click is that little shotgun thing
out of his left hands
do you have meteor strike to you just
say no
rising up our cuts oh that guy tried to
charge punch you
no no I'm get the help the fire will
take care of two of them I owe you
avoided the meteor egg with you kids
Oh No yeah those like long hallways are
really good I would be on and put them
to sleep 6490 you can't rock it punch in
the air and Mikhail bleedy you can only
do the shift and then rocket punch but
then the rocket punch never like you
can't aim it up you can only aim it
forward or downwards like if you're
jumping then yeah you can still do it
though you just kind of float right yeah
Olli
some people hate losing just probably
why he's mad that someone's using Farah
but man some people want to do the
science a dot a dash or shout out to
Daniel Fernandez well someone has a
widow come on that's a bar get Danish
man it's too hard to say if he's Opie
owner or weak or whatever because coming
from a widow
oh no the outplays are happening meteor
oh you got site that is so stupid he was
in the building and he like teleported
through the building
hey come on Joey right like all right
stupid fun okay yeah but but it's like
they think they're safe out there
Oh tonight vodka
I hope you get play of the game I know
that'd be hilarious that it is not Terry
Crews for everyone asking he is not the
voice actor also don't know this will be
good for competitive you might know that
freaking rocket barrage is gonna get it
yeah achievements can you see oh yeah
I'll go check after the dang teepee
going far as yeah come on I got my own
highlight reel I'm sure I dunno leave
this I leave in it we'll play one or two
more and then we'll call it a day you
know we got highlights right here
Hollywood yeah alright let's see if it
was this one yeah our own play the games
highlight of the game Oh wasn't it
wait oh this is the SS a double kill
there was another one in Hollywood me
check that one but that was the last
game okay doofus does have a sort of of
arranged weapon Cameron it's a shotgun
that you see there but it's kind of
short range it doesn't have that much
grain just someone we yeah and then the
cream and the guy gets me from behind
yeah they don't do that alright get into
another game holes I'm looking up again
here's achievements achievements since
Rocket Man what was that one at the top
those are the ones I have these are the
ones I don't know yet all right well
let's go at a time we just tried to show
his achievements it's not in there my
loop box live in case you might randomly
get a like legendary so we are searching
for a game uh I don't think doofus skips
like day he looks pretty pretty balanced
but then again he has robotic legs so I
don't I don't know it's like she knows
here rising type stuff going on can't
show us I can't show you guys that his
skin because doesn't have any right now
he doesn't have any he doesn't have any
skin or emotes or voice lines the only
thing he has is his golden fist there
are his abilities yeah pretty cool stuff
I'm Eric that's Joey just as a reminder
if you didn't know already playing
overwatch doofus has finally made his
way to PTR which is the public test
realm it's on PC only not on the
consoles so if you have PC overwatch
just switch your regions to PTR public
test realm and you can download through
fist and play him today we do not know
when he's coming out
hopefully in a couple of weeks we're all
doing this now yeah
but thank you guys YouTube Facebook
Twitter twitch everyone GameSpot as well
for tuning in checking this out I really
appreciate it
how far does the punch actually travel
it travels pretty far so I can get to
that building from here let's watch
close pretty close yeah that's like
almost like a full like once I do the
others yeah it's pretty far oh the
really narrow tunnel like if you missed
in this corridor you should be ashamed
of yourself you should just have a
q-dubs
right Oh No
okay does he still have his then what
okay so the stairs are there okay I was
like dude you just go through the ground
oh why would you come up with no life
man that's it's basically like Winston
but with a little bit more verticality
because of your left
so good no no oh oh you do not forc okay
what's the range they'd be a shotgun
hands is patbot range
dicen yeah I can reach pretty far is
just that it spreads far as it goes I
don't do that much damage you can only
do four at a time Z's actually IRISA
what's wrong with me just right turn
yeah yeah they're all over there nice Oh
get away you can't get up there that's a
road hog man I'll watch out the road hog
is am let me go around you aim it down
you can't right
oh that Anna solo yeah later
it's like a junk rat right there
come on got the heels that's good medium
here oh you use it right away yeah why
is that you says Mario Luigi one for one
yeah kind of I don't think the reload
time changes in terms of like by mailing
you could try what weird is going on I
can't say the voice actors name it's too
hard to pronounce I would fight butcher
it but Thank You Lola Vegas 85 or Lola
Vega oh you have meteor
oh that mm-hmm at least that somehow it
did not take up your your chart though
what charge
so like you're charging your rocket
punch and then he hooked you but it
didn't totally pull down yeah that's
good
good to know need help
dark Megaman shoutouts to you thanks for
tuning in do not know when he comes out
for console guys unfortunately I'm sorry
everyone that has PC version of
overwatch is able to use a compass you
just got to download the PTR patch no I
didn't make it but you know that move
doesn't work how you're gonna eat well I
thought it was I was high enough to get
to the jelly's hey he he's like a big
geek planet asking where's the other
gauntlet nobody ever just makes one
glove maybe they could only make one
glove it's kind of like over the top
have you watched over the top the movie
with Sylvester Stallone it's like he's
like an arm wrestler he's got one big ol
arm and that's it oh he's gonna be a
remember you can always left-click the
camera unless you're trying to hope that
somebody would do that Bing lasts long
time oh good night gets a triple potties
pot of good play it the gambler what
does that kind of shield so he gets
shield as a passive ability if he uses
it uses his abilities
it gives them shield when I smash it
look like you got like four bars of
shield which is pretty crazy so like
that's a good getaway escape type of
thing as well as like a way to get
shield so you can left click cancel your
yeah rocket punch but it does take up
the cooldown it's kind of like when
you're Winston and you're super low and
you have to alt and you're like okay I'm
gonna use the Hulk now you have to get
like a second satellite
oh we flew into the wall so that's more
damage if you guys didn't know that so
punching them into a wall yeah but he's
also crazy for trying to go like you
just got boost in like his IQ drop like
50 points that's wise every time I'm
boost I'm like okay I guess I gotta go
in now gotta go ham oh and I could have
been dangerous that's it like almost
winter damage we are not the retail
video game seller Game Stop weird
GameSpot thank you for tuning in
but I don't know how you join the game
stop I guess you could just go apply for
them as their max wind up on his rocket
punch Alex Brown there is you can see
that like like his kind of like his a
shotgun firing there is a prompt that
comes up for his charge punch that has
four bars when you charge it up to four
then you're maxed yeah meteor two
the triple get the quad okay that works
eat that's all right okay tranquility Oh
dated you might get playing the game
with that maybe and if you do then we
can end on a high note
okay we can end on a high note the
somber assault remove a shield probably
nice oh okay cleric kill streak he is an
offensive character sloth gaming do you
feel he's balanced says Victor two five
one one suku I mean we cannot tell you
ready to play with like a real team at
some point this is just crazy doom fist
a limit like you know crazy doing this
action right now via the PTR releases of
characters are never a good time - yeah
seems like if they're balanced or not oh
[ __ ] yeah I'm hearing some people in the
in-game chat like they're some of them
are not able to charge up the punch oh
really
like this might be like a little fun
like that like oh I tried holding any
just automatic it goes that works stay
out of his way
Oh Widow oh you're so dead oh wait you
got heals up yeah I can't Trump that
though you can't charge anything all
right now that's pause just bug so
testing four is four
maybe you just have to die no it'll work
Oh grapple away you go behind you behind
you there we go
alright so his charges back so there's a
little bit of a little bit of a bug like
I've seen that in them also having times
worn I can't press easy to so Matt you
have your alt T which is good see you
so I'm putting on a date of release for
consul and I don't know if I can
actually do that so oh my that doesn't
that doesn't seem balanced do you think
that's balanced
yes balance teleports through a room
okay no I went up the stairs oh okay oh
yeah they push it I got I got one more
life in me dude if you had alts you
could have altered this payload and I
may be stalled this well I think solo
all op8 pushing it it's all up to you do
this
oh oh oh okay we're good
oh we good you know doc
all right let's hope let's hope you got
it let's hope you got it here [ __ ] come
on play again yeah come on
well it's not us well I can I can watch
that highlight later
my mine was cool I thought yours cooler
because you got the double and then you
killed the one yeah whatever
uh yeah you wanna play one more I'll let
you have one more okay I'll let you have
one more that's it get that play the
game get you one more see if we can get
a play the game type lotion pocket Mon
says what do you think his legendary
skin should be hmm
well we were hoping for a one-punch I am
but there's no way they'll do that cuz
if it's so well you know one punch like
whether what our other characters with
like one big John really Spencer oh boy
on a commando okay oh we would show you
the Golden Gun but we're in a game I
think I think real quick this sometimes
it stalls a little bit okay yeah well
cam I wish we got it too later
Wow there goes okay that's a got skin
someone saying someone saying Astro Boy
Astro Boy see small though Jax why realm
I mean like what what other like armor
could you put on him that would make
them look like another character someone
say Captain Falcon Oh give them like the
helmet sunglasses Incredible Hulk
uh yeah no no Hellboy someone saying
he'll boil boy like a red we're just
hypothetically thinking what they could
be if there were skins there are no
skins for us to check it out though so
once I buy skin from leek I don't know
how that would necessarily work but sure
I guess but yeah pretty cool stuff
someone saying some of the skins from
the posters a new Bonnie
I hope says uh thanks to you three oh
yeah those mighty bought mighty bison or
Balrog war chief black hand
yeah I can I can kind of see them in
like a military outfit mm-hmm I tear
your crew skin it's just no shirt at all
hi look at you I wrapped in a towel
round oh he's alive
oh hello randoms cooking guy from the
all the way around kind of John Cena Old
Spice skin dinos with Infinity Gauntlet
says Nick M
oh nice hood good Oh
one punch baby hanim
too late it look like I'm screwed oh
that guy would have been so screwed cuz
he would have punched him into a wall
Oh what you could have meteor smash
after that too man I would have been
sick okay Chuck Norris liking it cyborg
from teen titan Kimbo Slice is young
console yet no he's not he's only a
public test realm on PC hello Corrine
Tom how are you Oh naughty that you
almost got me too many for you but I
didn't say it I don't know why he's not
voiced by Terry Crews youngness skk
Artie
so he jumped up in there oh sure you can
Tiger uppercut I'm here
sure you can
oh no oh that's a good run that's good
darkness angel 1360 pox skin I don't
know someone saying Terry audition
couldn't get the accent I was a meteor
strike from our spawn he's basically
galio Gallio is a champion from legal
legends yeah okay oh my god why is so
many people here
TMP activated a meteor though
I like that you are hoping this on a
show up yeah oh oh that guy was hacks to
stay back some health almost more by the
Gallio says Dave D yeah I can't can't
jump away well he has to let it go right
away to don't mean like when I'm jumping
here sometimes BQ I'm confirming much
more like like he should have some
winner
Winston interactions hopefully I mean we
had a Winston our team or playing
against the Winston earlier and nothing
happened
okay oh nice
I thought that punch was gonna kill him
for sure blind sucker punch can he ate
my words with the fish card no he can't
no knuckles can Alex Brown I don't think
they should do that and I'm not gonna
say it's bad Colossus from x-men a Jax
came from world combat maybe but Jax is
both both his arms are like mechanical
age a Valkyrie I'm reading twitch and
YouTube trying to keep an eye out on
GameSpot as well as
right away
later yeah buddy
how long can you hold the alt in the air
says bloke the King have some I tried
seconds it what to see Oh
bad timing Joey let it go too early
Oh
madness why haven't I answered all
10,000 questions post in the last 30
seconds I don't know man it's pretty
it's a good question could do miss level
skyscraper skin baby doc moments
overwatch moments yeah I think that I
haven't played him yet but from what
I've watched she looks like a fun
character Joey's having a lot of fun
when I asked him earlier to basically
first thing he said was he's a lot like
a away from me so is a cable skin
oh you try to pre-fire the punch what
are one two three four five six about
six
I think it's the time until it hits the
max of your circle all right it looks
like you know how it starts like oh yeah
actually knows okay you'll see it later
six man hi hi anyone on dude we saw
someone do it 303 hi play this guy now
that I'm working with oh yeah
can you charge in the air you can as
long as your use of shift you can but
you can't aim it into the air
someone says doom fist was arya a lot of
people have been saying that adrienne
art will try to explain so his left
click his ship does like a rising
uppercut he goes up into the air he also
knocks up a character hero if they're
there next to you the e ability is like
a almost like a winston like for like
leap in a way and that does like a smash
like in a frontal cone EMP
there's the rising uppercut there was
the e so it's a little front frontal
tone fire is that left click
well guys get them we always have all
together pretty seems pretty fast yeah
it does do a knock up yep kreygasm
they got out of it so you do as as the
opposing team you will see the the
meteor strike this circle the last like
second or so a a meteor strikes I move
your face oh he doesn't see you and you
do any more damage off the rocket punch
if you hit him into a wall as well as
being able to cancel it - or do you just
get uppercut it oh not even get uppercut
it off the thing no I'm not coming to
the air though yeah does he have a melee
attack yes with his baby hand is what I
like to call his real strong arm looks
pretty easy as dodge assault it's hard
to say cuz he can actually come down
pretty quick with it so I don't know you
kind of hear it and then have the dodge
right away but yeah it so you just got
make sure like earlier I got caught in
the stairwell oh yeah and then you just
win in throw them like by himself oh
yeah antara yeah it is a passive oh wow
okay see whether here's the meters this
was earlier that you're smashed about
200
wait blank reading she like he did
something cooler I know I did but sure
21 damage he does have a passive sorry
every time he uses his ability and does
damage with it it gives him a little bit
of shield he can go up to I think the
people are saying 400 yeah well I think
so but then that shield isn't like a
permanent shield like Sombra or two
you're born pure burn it like slowly
takes away yeah Bionic Commando for the
wind that really cool new dog I'm not
sure all the counters yet sergeant where
was it sergeant Duncan we know far I was
probably one though we had time uh are
you so you can defend and we'll call it
quits after yeah don't know when you
guys are getting in on console yeah
you're right
nefarious lock cuz that is a strong hand
leave the baby hand is a strong hand can
you use his alt in air after uppercut no
I don't see why not
we'll have to test that we don't have it
we can't see any skins emotes or play
the games and stuff like that so sorry
for those asking already thinking about
combos wombo combo yeah it's a good
thing to think about oh you know what
you could do though you could do like if
saria's doesn't work you could do the
Rhinehart or even there or me yeah or me
yeah any of those stun olds steam Oh 32a
I'm not sure how much his alt does I saw
him kill someone earlier for 60 damage
but I don't know if that was just
assault why is he considered DPS because
all his moves are offensive
oh [ __ ] good job buddy I saw coming I
just I knew it I knew it was coming I
got the Polly Queen in twitch i it's too
hard to talk about balance if he's ope
if he's not like if he's under like
whelming
you have to see it in a real environment
not a sixty-six student this environment
or like however many it is some people
are trying hard counters though yeah we
have a Reaper some bro and widow here
you cannot rocket fist into the air
Tyler you have to use the ship ability
and then use rocket then use the rocket
fist Oh God
no you're not
show them the Mele wouldn't come back
I'm gonna lay that is his melee his alt
is meteor strike you'll see it in a
second not sure how the onna
supercharged would affect him but could
be ok goofy may Rhines aria is pretty
good wombo so he ejected in the area are
you trying to do the that's weird I
guess you had collision with the wall
yeah ooh
wanna see me get this Hanzo right here
okay only it's only better because he
called it
Wainwright from an oversized boxing
glove would be funny and silly though we
choose
Arisa is one of his counters because she
doesn't get affected by his CC abilities
and fortifies as the pasty prince and me
it makes sense right now like as you
were saying she was specifically built
to counter doom fist yeah we tried it
for a second it seemed pretty good I
mean like the only reason it didn't look
as good cuz you're fighting for doing
videos but in the one situation it
seemed pretty pretty on like whole is
pretty good against it yeah I think cuz
he needs to get close and
you push shift + left click will it work
left click + shift + left click so ease
the fairway that's frightfully posh so
he probably means right click yeah baby
hand I mean strong hand
Oh Hanzo do you think he'll know
[Music]
upstairs so you would have had to have
jumped up and then media I think so it
sucks
oh just that next time oh wow
get rekt so he only did like a hundred
damage - when you're at like about 250
ish yeah he's pretty much been doing
that Zachary leo
he's been knocking them up and then
ground-pounding were there they
generally land how much knock them up
mainly them while they're in the air and
then Graham out okay give that extra 30
damage I don't know exactly how much
damage the rocket charge does but we
have seen it - a like a hundred percent
damage without even hitting the wall
right hitting the wall probably for sure
is gonna be Oh No
I think if you hit them in the wall for
sure they're probably gonna die yeah but
yeah that's okay
Oh - Hans OHS telerate he gets oh no oh
it didn't work
oh that did not hit him can you make
doofus a high work son our key TV no he
is an offensive character sweet all
right
well as we mentioned earlier there are
no skins no highlight intros no emo etc
they're just not out yet that is not you
it will check it out
I think you got what you got what you
got oh I think your strike she can't go
anywhere pretty good he's in so yeah
that was doom fist he is currently on
PTR the public test realm that's on PC
if you own overwatch you can download
that for free just select your region
and select PTR download the update Thank
You Joey so much for playing doom fist
today
yes final thoughts for you just a lot of
fun got it that's first and foremost I
think yeah that's it that's all he's got
okay so thank you everyone for tuning in
on twitch YouTube Twitter Facebook
GameSpot please follow us on twitch give
us a like and whatnot also subscribe to
YouTube so that you guys know when we go
live we're gonna do live streams every
day at 11 a.m. Pacific Standard Time
and a couple here and there for special
events and whatnot and also just because
we have cool features and things like
that that you guys should be notified
for really appreciate your guys's time
today chatting with us again just meet
Eric that's Joey see you guys next time